es ist wirklich mysteriös 2016 muss mehr
als 20 us diplomaten quasi aus gruber
fliehen 2018 das gleiche in china auf
sie alle waren wirklich geheimnisvolle
anschläge verübt worden
das ganze hat wirklich das zeug zu einem
spionagethriller denn niemand hatte auch
nur einen blassen schimmer was die
furchtbaren schmerzen kopfschmerzen
schwindel sprachstörungen und sogar
hirnschwellung und nasenbluten
hervorgerufen hatte sie hörten seltsame
geräusche und dann kamen die seltsamen
symptome jetzt scheint es geklärt krieg
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
die us-regierung tab bis heute im
dunkeln bei einer anhörung konnten die
vertreter der regierung nur mit den
schultern zucken zitat die us regierung
kennt keine waffe sei es ultraschall
oder anderes die die effekte hervorrufen
können wie sie bei den patienten aus
kuba beobachtet wurden
doch jetzt ist eine medizinerin der
university of california in san diego
wohl auf die lösung der mysteriösen
symptomen gekommen beatrice golomb
scheint die lösung für das rätsel zu
haben
zitat ich habe mir angeschaut was bisher
über die effekte gepulster radio und
mikrowellen bekannt ist und ob dies zu
den symptomen der diplomaten passt und
es passt gepulste strahlung im bereich
von 2,4 bis 10.000 megahertz kann
geräusche im ohr erzeugen die einen
klicken summen klopfen oder zum thenen
ähnlich wie es die diplomaten berichtet
haben so die wissenschaftlerin
durch die strahlung wird das ohr mit
gehörgang trommelfell hörschnecke und so
weiter aufgeheizt wodurch genau solche
geräusche erzeugt werden die dann im ohr
selbst entstehen dieser feier effekt
entsteht auch in der nähe von starken
rabe anlagen und von hochfrequenz
sendern
zitat wir haben solche symptome aber
auch schon in den tagen des kalten
krieges gesehen als die sowjets die
us-botschaft in moskau mit solchen
strahlen traktierten so der
umweltmediziner david carpenter von der
university of albany er war nicht an der
studie beteiligt aber noch mehr passt
zum einsatz von mikrowellen waffen zitat
auch die schlafstörungen kopfschmerzen
und kognitiven ausfälle passen
ins bild selbst die in hirnscans
nachgewiesenen veränderungen stimmen mit
dem überein was für mit radio oder
mikrowellen bestrahlt personen berichtet
wird ob sie sprich die us diplomaten
sind mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit mit mikrowellen
waffen bestrahlt worden
und da mutet es schon etwas seltsam an
dass sich die us-regierung so dumm
stellt oder es ist sogar absicht denn
die usa forschen seit rund 15 jahren
genau an solchen waffen vielleicht
wollen sie sich dabei nicht in die
karten schauen lassen alles schon sehr
mysteriös wir halten euch auf dem
laufenden also aber nicht vergessen und
jetzt clixoom wird werbefrei keine
briefe mehr mit eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir
die werbung von jeweils einem video im
monat ab bald ist es beim ersten video
soweit werdet also mitglied hier unter
dem video draufklicken und bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos exklusive live
streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien einen riesen dank an all
diejenigen die schon dabei sind wenn ihr
immer garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann endet mich
übrigens bei whatsapp dann bekommt ihr
den link zum video vor allen andern von
mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach
hier draufklicken und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch darauf glichen die
erste laserwaffe der welt bis dann
bleibt dran